Do I get to practice go?
Never done it before.
This is gonna be rubbish.
I think I've got an advantage on this one.
Yeah, I think so.
All right. For this challenge...
You seen this before?
Yeah, I think I seen it before, yeah .
I've seen this,
I think I saw Jackie Chan do it once
behind the scenes of Rush Hour
or something like that.
Where he put some coins
on the back of his hand.
And the challenge was to flick
all the coins up in the air
and grab each one with a
different grasp with the hand.
So pretty much like this.
Right? That was two.
All right.
Now the challenge for today
is to do three coins
and the loser's forfeit
is to have a heavy object lobbed
into the side of their head
to hopefully move the
skull inside the face.
All right.
Yeah?
Yeah. Yeah, sure.
So first person do it wins.
Ready?
Ready.
Ugh.
It's gonna be embarrassing.
Right.
Okay, I guess I'm ready.
Yeah, go for it.
Ahh.
That was pretty bad.
I just love the way you caught one,
got the other,
punch the other one
and then it went miles ahead.
And you're like,
yeah, I can still get that.
Uh.
I hadn't realized I punched it
until I'd already gone for the grab.
Got good feelings about this one.
You can't do that.
I can't get more than one.
The first catch.
Ahh!
Getting the hang of it now.
Oh!
Yeah.